Welcome to episode 11 of The Last Cyberneticist. This episode is called Multenions and Program Synthesis.
Over the last few episodes we have been building a set of foundations and a ladder around
a very small machine. Episode 7 asked what it means for a machine
to remember. Episode 8 asked when a difference becomes consequential. Episode 9 investigated
what has to be true before a comparator light can count as an evidentiary statement.
Episode 10 introduced Multenions as a historical attempt to make
objects, transformations, and invariants explicit. So for today, I want to ask a question that
sounds modest, but it's really where a great deal of technical thinking becomes either
machinery or stays a beautiful diagram on paper. And
that question is, when do rules become an algorithm? This is not the same question as
whether we have a formula. It's not the same question as whether we know the answer in
a particular case. An algorithm is a promise of conduct. Given the stated kind of input,
it tells us what elementary action to take, what to inspect next, when to repeat, and when
to stop. It is an account of how a result comes into the world. Otherwise, an algorithm
is a promise of conduct. The mathematician, Boris Trakhtenbrot, begins his 1963 book
Algorithms and Automatic Computing Machines with the familiar numerical work, Decimal
arithmetic, and the Euclid method for finding a greatest common divisor. That choice of
beginning that discussion is very useful. From the very beginning, it prevents us from treating
an algorithm as a glamorous word, reserved for electronic machines, or something that
we can obfuscate away. A person, an individual, can carry out an algorithm with a pencil and
paper. A calculator can carry it out without any understanding of the larger mathematical
purpose. So what matters is the work has been decomposed into explicit and repeatable steps.
In Trakhtenbrot's version of the Euclid method, take two positive integers.
If they're equal, stop. That common value is the answer. If they're unequal, put the
larger and smaller in order, subtract the smaller from the larger, and then repeat with
the new pair. The number of repetitions is not known in advance. It depends on the input.
But every next move is known at every stage. So conversely, subtract the smaller from the
larger and repeat with the new pair. Again, the same repetitions. But the moves are known
at every stage. This small example gives us four questions to ask
about any proposed procedure. What inputs are permitted? What are the elementary operations?
Which condition chooses the next operation? And what counts as completion? If any one
of those answers is left as a private intuition, we may have a useful suggestion, but we do
not have an algorithm in the strongest sense. So looking at what we've been doing here,
"Compare the target and the candidate, then improve the candidate. Well, that's a
sounds like a procedure. That's what it sounds like, right? But how do we improve
it? What's that actually mean? So which difference is inspected? Which change is allowed? What
if two changes look possible simultaneously, right? What if the numbers are already equal?
What happens if the comparison is invalid? The input is absent, or a limit is reached? We talked
a lot about this in the last episode. But again, it's to enforce the point that the difference
between a slogan and a controller lives in those very questions. Trakhtenbrot
gives two names to the further parts of that promise. So an algorithm is general for a
stated class. One finite method must work for every permitted instance, not merely the
example that inspired it. And it is determinate. At each stage, it must say what happens next.
Generality does not mean omnipotence. It means that the domain has been named honestly. Determinacy
does not mean the result is known from the start. It means a procedure never asks its
operator to supply an unrecorded act of judgment. And we've ever heard that before. There is
another distinction here, which is almost unfashionable to say aloud. So an algorithm can
exist and still be practically useless at a given scale. So, digging that a little more,
a method can be perfectly specified, completely mechanical, and far too slow or too expensive
to use. Speed is not the definition of intelligence. It's not even the definition of an algorithm
although I want you to believe that. Feasibility is a separate question. One of responsible
design or has to ask himself or herself, whatever it's stated and what it's actually
doing. I'm telling you all about it, all this super intelligence now, I guess we've evolved
into. What is it actually doing? We didn't figure out what the AI, the artificial intelligence
is doing. But now it's just rebranded. Okay. That's why the word algorithm is critical
with the series. It gives us a way to resist the familiar kind of spectacle. So we don't
need to claim that a small controller solves every problem or that
a visible result. It proves a mysterious faculty. There's cognition right there. We
can ask the smaller, more durable questions. What class of situation was this built for?
What state can it recognize? What is it authorized to change? What record does it leave behind?
Can another person, a human, or maybe even agent, follow the chain from input to action
to result. I think the human observation point of that would be more welcome. So the new
research on McAulay's multenions makes the first half of this question sharper. So multenions
are not a hidden name for an eight-part octonion machine.
But in the general four-dimensional case, he describes an associative, noncommutative
graded algebra with 16 scalar components. So it has named primitive units, products
whose ordering matters. It makes a difference. Grade projections, vectoriums, linear operations,
he calls linities, and invariant pairings. Now the invariance is a, that's the part to
pay attention to the most. That's the valuable part. But all these things we just talked
about all that list is valuable. This is all valuable because it tells us what the algebra
can do. It can make the terms of an operation explicit. It can say that a product is lawful.
It can say that changing the order of two primitive units changes the sign. It can distinguish
the scalar part from a vector part or a grade two component from another grade. It can name
a transformation and state an identity that it preserves. But all of those things as great
as they are, none of those facts chooses an operation in time. So I'm looking at the most
primitive sense or the most basic sense. Two of the compact relations that we need visible
among all else are these two expressions, i sub 1 squared equals negative 1. i sub 1
times i sub 2 equals the negative of i sub 2 times i sub 1. So the first says, the first
point I said is multiplying the first primitive unit by itself gives a negative 1. The second
says that exchanging the order of the two units changes the sign. We said it in the
text but there's a numerical representation for it. But neither relation by itself tells
a physical machine and two stored symbols to be treated as i sub 1 and i sub 2. Whether
the order has been preserved in memory or what should happen when an unfamiliar symbol arrives.
So the algebra does not decide whether a product should be attempted, displayed, rejected,
logged or deferred. So those are the algorithmic and the architectural questions. So that gives
us two layers and neither can replace the other. So the first, let's review a bit here,
the first is the algebraic layer. What is the object? What basis is it written in? Which
grade does it have? What product or projection is permitted and which relation should remain
true? The second is the algorithmic layer. Where is the object stored? What input makes
an operation available? Which transition is selected? What changes in memory? What check
follows? And what ends the run? I would state here that an algebra without an algorithm
is a map with no route. A program without an algebraic contract may run, but it's important
terms can remain private habits in the head of the author. So let's do an example on that.
That's a good thing to bring home. Suppose a small program says it will work with two
primitive units, i1, i2. Before it performs anything, it has to declare what those names
mean, where they are represented, and which rule it is testing. So let's give it the
request, multiply i1 by i2. The algebra tells us that the ordered product has a meaning.
But the algorithm still has work to do. It must validate that both operands use the declared
basis. It must preserve their order. It must execute the named product. It must store
the result in a layout whose grade can be identified. It must test the result against
the expected relation, and then finally must record what happened. If the machine instead
receives i2, followed by i1, it is not allowed to treat that as a harmless rearrangement.
The order is part of the meaning. The program must either produce the negative result, as
prescribed by the rule, or enter an error because representation cannot preserve its
sign. So, the clever ones listening here can say, "I want you multiplying." The order
is irrelevant. Be careful on making assumptions before you execute the process. That's the
point of this one. I'm telling you this. A correct-looking final lamp, even in your head,
is not enough. The route by which that lamp was reached belongs to the
claim. It's segueing back into the book by Trakhtenbrot, chapter 2. It gives us a second
way to see why. Here he considers finite two-player games with perfect information. No hidden
cards, no dice, no accident smuggled in as fate. No cheats, in other words. A game position
is drawn as a tree. Each vertex is a position. Each edge is a permissible move. The leaves
of this tree are the finished games. Wins or losses. The important distinction in the
discussion is between a move and a strategy. A move may look clever at the opening. A complete
strategy says what to do in every situation that can arise, including positions the player
hopes never to see. Working backward from the leaves, one can label a position as winning
if the player whose turn it is, has at least one move to a winning successor. If every
permitted move hands the win to the other player, the position is losing. This is the
winning strategy, the losing strategy proposal. This is quite common in the world. This does
not imply that you play chess by brute force. There is an explicit separation of the theoretical
existence of a procedure and its practical feasibility. A finite game tree may be so
vast that the procedure is useless to a person in the moment. Within a stated class, a complete
strategy can be defined because each position is answered by the structure of the whole
tree. For our purposes, the controller is not a game opponent, but the lesson transfers
cleanly. A controller needs an answer for every reachable state. If the target matches
the candidate, what follows? If it does not, what action is chosen? If a sensor value
is outside the representation contract, where does the system go? If a branch is unavailable,
is there another prescribed branch, an error state or halt? An arrow for the happy path
is not a strategy for the machine. So there's a moral restraint in that.
We should refrain from calling a device autonomous because it produces an output after a prepared
demonstration. The serious question is whether its permitted situations have been bounded
and whether its response to each one has been made legible. A small, finite controller can
be modest in capacity and rigorous in that respect. That is already an achievement.
A very vivid example comes up in chapter 3 of Trakhtenbrot's book. So a labyrinth
is a finite graph made of junctions and corridors. You all kind of know what a labyrinth or a
maze looks like and those are two different things, but don't get into it in the moment.
So in the story, the Greek myth of the labyrinth and the minotaur, the question is not whether
the Theseus is inspired, whether it goes into the go and get the minotaur is the storyteller's
pleasure. For our purposes, it is whether a designated target junction can be
reached from a designated start. Trakhtenbrot's procedure gives the searcher a
form of external memory. In brief, the story is Ariadne gives Theseus a ball of yarn and she
holds one end of it. Theseus heads into the labyrinth. He can search for the Minotaur.
And as he's traversing the labyrinth, the corridors that he has not been in yet, the
first of them is green. Once he has traversed that corridor, we mark it yellow.
When he retraces that path,
that same corridor, perhaps in the opposite direction, to wind the string, we identify
that corridor as red. So the colors are not the decoration for the story, but it's making
the states visible. So at a junction, the procedure follows an ordered list of rules. Stop
if the target has been reached. Backtrack, when the loop has been closed. Otherwise,
take an untraversed, green corridor. Return and stop at the origin when the exploration
has fully come back there, so return to the origin. In the remaining case, in the
backtrack along the appropriate yellow corridor. Most importantly, never enter a red corridor.
Because that's where one becomes lost. So there's, I would state, there's a beautiful,
beautiful invariant in this procedure, in the very process. And on the level of an
epiphany, I would state. Because when you think about it, at every moment, or any moment,
the yellow corridors form one simple path, from the start to the traveller's present location.
So the yellow path is the thread. So it doesn't just say where the guy is, the traveler is,
but how the present state was reached. So we had two pieces at the same time. Since the
labyrinth is finite, and no corridor is used more than twice, the procedure must halt. It
either reaches the target, leaving a simple route back, or returns to the origin after
exhausting all reachable territory. And that description I just gave is a remarkable physical
picture of memory. It's not a pile of data accumulated somewhere, wherever. It's a recoverable
history with a current function. The markings distinguish what is untried, what is currently
active, and what has been exhausted. They prevent pointless repetition. They make a negative
result meaningful: not "we failed to find the target, but "we searched this finite, stated
region under this procedure and return to no unexplored corridor available. You know everything
that's going on, and you remember why. So there's a small add on here, I say a small,
but crucial repair in Trakhtenbrot's account. A rule that says take any green
corridor is not determinate. So in that case, so a labyrinth has a structure without that
has single pathways. So there's no choices involved, but a maze has choices involved.
So a rule that says take any green corridor is not determinate because two searchers can
make two different unrecorded choices for different reasons. So in the book, he
repairs this by requiring a fixed convention. So such as choosing the first
eligible corridor clockwise from the direction of entry. So the convention perhaps can be
a bit arbitrary, but it must be fixed in algorithmic sense. So it has
to be a rule for that in that situation when you come upon a maze rather than labyrinth.
So that's exactly the kind of ordinary phrase that hides the machine's most consequential
ambiguity. Choose an available rewrite. Try a nearby value. Select the best candidate.
Choose the next free register. Every one of those conceals a human choice unless an ordering
rule has been declared. A tie-breaker is not bureaucratic debris. It's when it turns
into intention into a reproducible path. Now that I'm putting my finger on is exactly
the rub, the major problem that we're having today. So episode four gave us the architecture
of vocabulary of the activities, modes, transitions, and conditions. Alright, Ariadne's thread. It
adds the missing historical dimension to that architecture. A state diagram can say
what a machine may do. The thread says what it actually did, what it tried, and how it
arrived here. Now if a controller has only one fixed sequence, validate, multiply, verify
halt. It's not a labyrinth. And it does not need to pretend to be one. But it must be
a search on a bounded set of possible transformations. Or rewrite paths, test branches, or fault
cases. It needs a Ariadne's thread. It needs to know which transition remains available,
which is on the active path, which branch has already been exhausted, and which fixed
rule chooses among the remaining possibilities. Now for any of you that haven't experienced
with assembly and low-level programming, design your branching, and you'll know what I mean.
Otherwise, the machine arrives at an answer without leaving anyone a route back to the
question. No responsibility, no traceability. We have no idea what it's doing. Reflecting
back to Trakhtenbrot. Chapter four, which is what I'll call that with here. It moves
from the finite corridors of the labyrinth, so we're getting out of these quarters kind
of things, but into a far more dangerous territory, I would say. Words and substitutions, people
would think that that's a very dangerous thing, but let me explain. So an associative calculus,
which is reticent in the quaternions, octonions, multenions world. In the case of algorithms,
begins with a finite alphabet and a finite collection of allowed replacement rules. One
word may be changed into another by applying a rule at an eligible position. Two words
are equivalent if a finite chain of such legal substitutions connects them. So in a very
terse way, it can look like a game with strings, but the word problem is not like that. That's
not what you think. So it asks a very severe question. Is there one method that decides
for every pair of words in a given calculus, whether they are equivalent? On inspection,
the associated graph, they're usually infinite, maybe not really, but the okay, they're infinite.
Every word is a vertex. Every lawful substitution is an edge. A method that tries, simply tries
substitutions can wander forever without proving that no connection exists. That's where we've
got to kind of lean into zips, zips law or not. But that's not the subject for this here.
Here Trakhtenbrot offers a constructive case in which the problem
can be solved. So the system is given directed reduction rules. Apply them in a fixed priority
order at the first eligible position. The process reduces every word to one of eight forms. The
argument does not stop with the observation that the strings have been changed. Rather,
it proves that the reductions terminate and then uses the parity invariants and an index
parity argument to show that no two of the eight reduced forms are equivalent. Two original
words are equivalent exactly when their final reduced forms match. That's how it's working
there. And we call that the normal form idea. And that's something we can use right away
in our work and our implementations. So a rewrite procedure is not a decision procedure
merely because it produces a tidy representation. But to use a final
form as evidence, We need to know that the reduction ends and that that final form is
meaningful enough to settle the question we asked. Termination and uniqueness or another
explicitly proved equivalence criterion are part of the design. See, not decorations
to add on after the demo works. So what's the most beautiful thing about this, I would
say, the takeaway and what leads to the epiphany is that chapter four, it's the geometric
example of words. So let me explain a little bit on that. So the geometric example grounds
the symbols. Letters stand for an elementary transformation of a square. Concatenating
letters composes these transformations. A substitution rule can express that two different sequences
have the same geometric effect. Formal marks are not empty merely because they are formal.
The interpretation must be stated and the operations on them must preserve the relations we claim
they represent.
Returning to the multenion problem, if we write a program that transforms symbolic
names for algebraic objects, we must say whether it's carrying out an algebraic product, changing
a storage encoding, reducing an expression to a canonical form, or
really rearranging display characters. But these are not interchangeable acts. The output
may look similar while the contracts differ completely. And this is what we're going to
dovetail into. This is where we're going to create a central claim. For a machine to make
a formal relation operational, it is more than valid symbols and more than a working
output. It needs a declared representation, a determinate transition rule, preserved invariants,
an explicit completion or failure condition, and a trace sufficient to reconstruct the run.
So you may recognize from the early episodes that parts of that sentence. And let me indicate
those. Episode seven, we said that memory is not merely accumulation, but the continuity
that can be recovered. So in episode eight, we said a difference matters, only when it
changes what happens next. And then episode nine, we stated that a visible signal counts
only as evidence under valid conditions. So here I've, I put them together in one statement.
Now those ideas meet. Memory becomes the thread, right? A consequential difference
selects a lawful branch. Evidence is the trace that lets another person walk the architectural
behavior backward. So closing, because I'm running on a bit here, I'm going to make up
a new term. So before calling a program, multenion-informed. Okay. We need six promises. So we
need an algebraic contract. The basis, grades, operations, and identities in use. We need
a representation contract: where those things live in memory or code. We need a transition
contract. What makes each operation available and which fixed convention resolves a choice?
We need an invariant contract. So what must remain true across every permitted step? We
need an evidence contract. That's the trace. And finally, we need a scope contract that
what limits we are not hiding. So we spend a little bit of time in the scope
contract because it deserves a little more reflection out here. A finite controller is
not a universal machine. A normal form that works in one stated calculus is not a solution
to every word problem. So a successful traversal of one bounded graph does not prove a general
method for every search space. Exact claims are not modesty theater. They are what makes
the work testable. So in practical terms, the trace for a small controller should be
able to say, hey, this was the input. This was the current state. This was the transition
chosen at this memory location or actuator changed. This check passed or failed. And this
was the reason for the halt or error or the declared step limit. So if the allowed number of steps
is reached before the target or an exhaustive result, an honest output is not a no solution.
It is `STEP_BOUND_REACHED` together with the active path and the unexplored frontier.
So it doesn't make the program intelligent by declaration. It makes it answerable. In
the next episode, we'll make that answerability visible in two small demonstrations. So first,
a declared algebraic operation will be validated, performed in order, checked, and recorded.
Then the Four-Bit Wonder's familiar target-and-candidate cycle will show how relation
becomes action only through an explicit algorithm. The concrete next action is to build a representation
table and transition trace before asking the machine to persuade us of anything. That's
for next time. Thank you for listening.